champions is coming to a close this
weekend and it's already come crashing
down for north american ballerin any
teams once heralded as the kings of
valorant but now all anyone can hear is
na is dead is done with over
so let's ask the questions
what went wrong in berlin and is any
valerian actually dead
[Music]
all right y'all before we get into the
video i gotta remind you as always hit
the like button the subscribe button and
to ring that notification bell if you
don't
na's never winning anything like ever
just in case you've been living under a
rock north america is out of vct
champions and for a quick recap north
america sent three teams to berlin
sentinel c9 blue and envy and all of
them fell they didn't fall without a
fight but they all fell nonetheless so
the teams who are supposed to be the
best in the world didn't even make it
out of the quarterfinals if any valorant
was supposed to be the best coming into
the tournament then what happened
valerant commentator and analyst
geocollins explained a lot of people's
expectations perfectly heading into
valerian champions 2021 conversation
around which major region emea in north
america or korea was going to take the
win was rife nah taken the early global
lead at masters reykjavik the
indomitable skill of sentinels affording
them no map losses in their conquest
sentinels lost to crew in what was a
devastating final round if you're an n a
fan and it all comes down to this 12 to
11 one team
beckoning for greatness and they're
gonna flash
three through the smoke heartbreak now
for sentinels as it's all down to dapper
and sick sick fighting with everything
but it is not enough as dapper now in
the 1v3 the flash comes through
you know you're going to pop here klaus
ready and holding though dapper it's
your time to shine right about now it's
all on you buddy surrounded all fronts
it's over it's done with crew against
all
of our expectations against all odds
send sentinels home
valorent was finally supposed to be the
game na would be the best at we had it
it was valerian it was ours first the
titans of sentinels were eliminated then
envy were eliminated
and then the very last type of n a
cloud9 blue had the entire fate of a
region resting on their shoulders two
detained on liquid
from the spider grenade is that gonna do
enough though to slow it down it's
halfway need to stop this there's the
frag from miss they need more though
they need more they need more because
there's a defuse and that team liquid
they eliminate the north american hope
in cloud nine blue and team liquid make
their way to the semi-finals and my god
i would be afraid to be facing them this
is a team that looks destined for a
grand finals there sean and so north
american fans are left with the question
what happened why have things suddenly
turned into a disaster for any valerian
and is it actually the disaster
everyone's making it out to be everyone
is pointing fingers at teams and players
trying to figure out whose fault this is
well the first reason we can point to is
that any players are no longer the best
or just no longer as dominant we could
simply look at how na performed in
berlin for example not only did the
teams not do well but ni just didn't
play as well as they could have or even
normally have maybe they're just worse
now like if you look at tenza's average
combat score in this tournament that is
not how we expect the best player in the
world to play and maybe because like
people have been suggesting on twitter
it's because na hasn't been putting in
the work
bro na is losing because these
[ __ ] practice for two to three
hours and stream for eight the streaming
point we cannot argue against
i
actively watch these people i wake up in
the morning watch some heat go then
switch to some annie shazam whoever
seems like someone is always on but in
my opinion this isn't the most fair
criticism i i do believe that it's an
easy and valid one to make as what we
viewers see but it's not the most fair
listen to shazam it sucks we're all sad
dude i could tell it affected the guys
everyone really cared
as much as people think we don't care
for the narrative that na doesn't care
or care about streams or whatever i
promise like i know our team tried
really hard
and we felt really good about it going
in we practiced a lot we had everything
drilled rehearsed i did a lot of prep
we just didn't deliver then there's this
na is washed pink hair buff pink hair
buff patty is greater than tens mda you
know you make a good point shazam had
the bleach you just needed the pink god
damn it maybe just maybe valerian isn't
established enough as a game and regents
haven't found consistency and play style
for a largely hampered coveted
environment all jokes aside the game has
truly changed a lot since sentinels
played their way into our hearts and
iceland at masters 2.
the game is still very young and has had
an incredibly tough environment to grow
up in we are reaching the end of our
first world championships players and
orgs are still trying to find their
footing in the competitive environment
think about how far this game has come
in just a year we have a new agent that
has impacted the pro meta significantly
in ko and an expanded map pool with
breeze and fracture not only that but
each of those two maps require teams to
expand their agent pool significantly to
find success it's basically consensus in
the pro community that you need to play
viper on debris and breach on fracture
and that is a lot to adjust to at the
highest level that comp changing is game
changing compare valorent to a game like
cs go
yes we're doing that calm down cs has
been around for over a decade and there
are dozens of lineups for utility to
memorize executes to master and strats
to understand and that's without agents
or abilities and not to be that valid
fangirl but i think that's what makes
ballerina really really great so
ultimately the answer to the question is
n a trash is
no
no
it is true to say that n.a failed in
berlin but it is not fair to say that n
a is a failure but we have to be sure to
separate the question of is n a dead
versus what went wrong in berlin they
are different questions what went wrong
in berlin is that any teams like
sentinels did not perform to our
standards for them and also these
standards they set for themselves i know
we lost but like or people were saying
like stuff about certain agents but um
i didn't feel uncomfortable with a role
in sky i feel like it fell apart in our
communication and like teamwork you know
we were criticized heavily um during
berlin masters 3 about like playing off
metacomp not playing the meta whatever
sticking up stuff that we used to um so
then we really grinded really grinded
like stuff that we even we knew during
master three that these were more
metacomps and this is how we wanted to
play but we just didn't implement it in
time and we figured that you know
through the practices leading up to
champions we were actually really
comfortable on each individual agent
like people were we were playing tons of
scrims um grinding rank on these agents
and uh i don't think it was people being
uncomfortable i think that no matter the
agents we played we failed at like the
the most basic level other regions like
sea and latam played better and largely
overperformed expectations is andy's
performance something to reflect on yes
and players from na agree with this also
you think i'm huffing any copium do you
see the shirt that i'm wearing look look
into my eyes and ask me about reykjavik
how do you think i feel about na but
don't take my word for it i ask players
who are not from the north american
region what they thought about the n a
is dead talk and this is what star xo
from ascend had to say of course not i
think it's it's it's very good still
like these losses like doesn't really
matter like one tournament they can beat
us one tournament we can beat us like is
he's just the
race you know who's better this
tournament i think they still have great
potential great players and he's just
banter between us you know
it's we're feeding each other like like
in league of legends
or csgo whatever whatever the game is
you just you just fight you know so my
prescription for na fans is just to wait
have heart and have patience we don't
know how the competitive meta will
continue to evolve we don't know how new
players entering the north american
region will impact the game we also
don't know how other regions outside of
north america will continue to grow as
sk rossi put it the beauty of losing is
it tells you how bad you are and things
to improve on tells you how close or far
you are to your goals a wake-up call
good thing right now what else we need
as a motivation to get better we have
found more equilibrium in the valorant
scene which makes it even more exciting
because the next time these teams meet
we have no idea who's going to come out
on top
that's kind of dope
i heard something about that against
phantoms we're not gonna talk danny
we're not gonna talk about it so okay so
like i interviewed him super awesome
interview super nice guy and i'm pretty
sure he was using the prism phantom skin
that day maybe i'll find screenshots
that day when i interviewed him he was
using a phantom skin and i was like oh i
like your fandom skinny one like oh
thank you the next day he played and it
was the recon phantom skin and i was
like whoa whoa whoa dapper
dj is it like i don't know like and he's
like because in my head i was like oh
like maybe like like he just changes his
phantom skin like tens changes his
settings and i'm pretty sure he kept the
recon skin for the rest of the time
sentences in the tournament